as far as contract goes i'm not
concerned with contract talks at all
like
i mean me and my agent talked briefly
about it and i told him i said
don't tell me anything about a contract
and until it's like something where it's
happening or
you know if it's something that i need
to know other than that like i mean if i
was my whole agent then i'll have
everything to tell you guys about a
contract but i'm not
and i don't i don't talk upstairs about
contracts i don't talk to coaches about
contracts
[Music]
alvin kamara not concerned about his
contract that's august 10th well there's
concern three weeks later
because alvin kamara according to adam
shafter of espn
unexcused absences for multiple days as
he tries to get his contract done now
i've seen
others say well he's injured and look
it comes down to are you really injured
or are you trying is he doing the rival
contract the riley reef thing we just
talked about i mean in his own little
way
you know yeah and and yes and it's not
it's not the deliberate i refuse to play
right
it's i'm injured and i can't play it's
the holding in
joe mixon last week the bengals running
back who's in the same posture
as alvin kamara missing multiple days
with migraines
and creating some messages with tweets
he sent out making people think that
he's
he's you know got migraines yeah
migraines and he's trying to
solve that migraine with uh you know a
large bag of money
which whatever tool you have
use it chris we talked last segment
about the possibility of a guy just
saying right before week one i'm not
playing you can't be that direct about
it
you have to say i'm injured and i can't
play yeah and that may be exactly what
camaro is doing and if he is so be it
get paid christie mccaffrey got paid
and the people within the saints
organization would say camaro is every
bit as good as christian mccaffrey they
just don't use him as much
then you better find a way to pay the
guy yeah no you know he's
he's like a christian he's the christian
mccaffrey of this offense that's what he
is
you know yeah he's a little banged up
last year we know that he told us that
at the super bowl he fought through
through some things i'm sure that scared
him you know this is a guy that's
again he's put in a lot of work he's
touched the ball a lot he's taken a lot
of hits
now he wants some reward i understand
that you know and
he's got the great leverage of he
is a key part and maybe other than
michael thomas and
this is arguable i think you could argue
this it's either
one of those two as far as the most
important part of that new orleans
offense so much of the run game and pass
game is formulated around alvin kamara
and that west coast offense
especially the pass game and that's
where drew brees can dissect defenses
and sean payton finds all these ways to
get in cute formations that are creative
and find all these ways to get thomas
and camaro the ball five yards on the
out route five yards over the middle
these option routes i mean
so he has great leverage as far as
talent is concerned
and then his scheme importantness
or importance i should say uh you know
as far as that's concerned he's got a
lot to argue there and that'll piss sean
payton off if he doesn't have that tool
to use him early on in the season and
usually
it's you know it's not like this for the
saints they don't have to deal with
issues like this
they get things under control now
michael thomas had to draw a line in the
sand last year but he finally got his
money
but it's always harder to show up
and shut down than it is to not show up
in the first place but you know the new
cba made it more expensive to hold out
so i think we're going to see more and
more guys hold in i think this is going
to be a trend and we've seen several
guys where we've at least wondered
is yeah what we knew we knew that melvin
ingram was doing right
with the chargers and there was
speculation dalvin cook may do it in
minnesota
we were wondering what has got a little
sweetener right
right right we're wondering what's up
with danielle hunter in minnesota with
all the practices he's missed i just
think when you see a guy and you could
objectively look at his contract and say
hey you know maybe this guy isn't
getting what he should get
if all of a sudden he's putting one
after another after another absences
together from practice you have to
wonder
it's fair to wonder is this an effort to
stay out of harm's way
until he gets the contract he wants
chris yeah yeah i mean and i'm not mad
at him if
it is you know how many times have we
had this conversation it's the most
brutal position in all of sports there's
nothing worse
i mean these guys get crushed uh so
between the physical abuse and then
his importance to that scheme and sean
payton and drew brees and everything
they do that way
and he's clearly one healthy the best
between the tackles runner for that
football team too
so there's a lot of things that he
brings to the table
that help that offense go from being you
know good to
really good to one of the best and
camara
camaro is certainly a big part of that
kamara excuse me
camaro you got america i had it right
reverted back to kamar tamara
camara kamara it's properly camara
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports